el último giro en un incidente que causó
una conmoción en francia el lunes por la
mañana cuatro policías involucrados en
la paliza al productor de música afro
michel sheckler fueron acusados de
rendir un falso reporte y de cometer
violencia deliberada por parte de una
persona con autoridad pública dos fueron
puestos tras las rejas por temor a que
pudieran concertarse entre ellos y
presionar a los testigos el fiscal de
parís que me exact también había pedido
que se le acusara de agresión racista y
putt éste negaron haber utilizado un
lenguaje racista como lo informó la
víctima y lo corroboró uno de los
jóvenes que estaba de pie detrás de la
puerta del vestíbulo negaron que las
actas de sus primeras declaraciones
fueran falsas pensaron que el local era
un salón de acceso abierto al público y
no un vestíbulo privado sin embargo
terminaron admitiendo que los golpes
eran injustificados y que habían actuado
por miedo una vez dentro del vestíbulo
son finalistas uno de los oficiales está
acusado de lanzar una granada de gas
lacrimógeno al estudio de música declare
la grabación de la agresión por las
cámaras de seguridad ha sido ampliamente
difundida en la
redes sociales añadiendo gasolina al
fuego sobre la polémica ley de seguridad
nacional que se abre paso en el
parlamento francés lo que restringiría
la afirmación de oficiales de policía si
la intención es dañar al oficial en
particular el sábado miles de personas
se manifestaron en todo el país contra
el proyecto de ley y la brutalidad
policial protestas que terminaron con
violencia en ambos lados dejando al
menos 98 agentes heridos según el
ministerio del interior mientras que se
desconoce el número de manifestantes
lesionados y al menos un periodista
resultó herido el cuestionado ministro
del interior- queralt hermana es un
fuerte partidario de la ley este lunes
deberá responder preguntas sobre el uso
de la fuerza ante el parlamento